conso maintenant c'est lors des foires
aux vins dans les supermarchés
l'occasion de faire plus ou moins de
bonnes affaires plus modestement c'était
l'heure des vendanges sur les hauts
plateaux et suresnes dans les
hauts-de-seine alors la confrérie des
buveurs de vin s'est réuni pour goûter
la cuvée 99 aller parait-il très
honorable on s'attend un vin plus
modestes pour l'an 2000
ce week-end c'était surtout l'occasion
de faire la fête car le vin c'est
d'abord ça il faut bien le dire regardez
ces drôles de personnages ne sont pas
les membres d'une secte très très très
étrange quoique heures ils font partie
de la confrérie du vin de suresnes
comme chaque année depuis 1984 date de
leur premier rassemblement
ils se réunissent pour déguster
justement la toute dernière cuvée et
comme chaque année le nouveau cru est
meilleur que le précédent
nous nous sommes très satisfait parce
qu'ils passent que 99 a eu un temps bien
meilleur que celui ci passe qui a pas eu
de pluie
donc c'est un vin très sec et bien
structuré bien charpenté ou un vin blanc
c'est très agréable pour vous le cru de
l'année prochaine qu'est ce que ça
devrait donner
écoutez c'est pas si catastrophique
parce que le mois de juillet qui n'a pas
été très bon moi je trouve que ce seras
prêt dès les graines sont assez balland
le voit depuis là ça nous donne envie de
la préparer avec plaisir cette grande
vendanges on pourrait être intronisé y
déguster la prochaine cuvée il suffit
d'habiter sur aisne d'être parrainé par
un membre de la confrérie et surtout
boire et aimer le vin de suresnes nous
mettent face aussi de l'humour aussi
donc c'est il faut pas trop se prendre
au sérieux
non c'est l'occasion de rencontrer des
gens de boire du vin également et de
boire du vin ce qui était un petit peu
un problème je ne vois pas le 20 mai
alors j'essaie de m'y mettre
comme tous les autres vins d'île de
france le vin de suresnes n'est pas
encore rentré dans la cour des grands
mais qui sait peut-être qu'un jour il
rivalisera avec les crues les plus
connus